and i remember he's like oh i gotta
change the intro i can't just say tifu i
gotta say faze tifu i was like
that was kind of kind of weird but then
um right after that i mean
we were filming i remember filming him
on his keyboard
and his mouse and he had his keyboard
instead of normal he had it vertical
yeah his keyboard turned like that and
he's like like this yep so we i don't
know what that was like he says more
room for the mouse or what it's just
better for his arm to like rest it's
just more natural than like
being over here i suppose i don't know
he
he like
he was a real trailblazer for for gamers
as a whole he was trying [ __ ] that
nobody's ever tried before like you know
you can bind your keys you know like
when you play a game like w e s d
whatever like yeah those are the keys
that run forward and side to side and
back and forth
um he would completely start from
scratch and just like
go through all these steps in his head
to try to figure out what binds would
just be the most efficient possible and
it's not like it's something that you
it's like playing styles you know it's
like whatever you do the most you need
to be the easiest to access but then you
need to like balance everything out as
well like i couldn't possibly go that
into depth about it but
that alone like that takes a lot
to set up all your keys and all your
guns and all your commands like
from scratch he's like he's like yeah i
just changed my binds it's going to take
me like three to four weeks to get used
to him and like
he'll just train and like reset his
brain to understand his keyboard
differently and just
destroy everyone you know insane
the amount of focus
that goes into that
intuitive too like he just does it he
doesn't even have to think about it
right yeah but like he does it so much
and he like he focuses so for such a
long period of time on that [ __ ]
it's like
it's just i admire just that level of
focus on one thing you know i mean he's
i
can will never be able to wrap my head
around the fact that he is
he won more tournaments than anyone has
ever won by far by like a long shot in
fortnight and fortnite is the most
popular game that's ever been created in
mankind there's never been anything more
popular than that to be the best at
the most popular game that's ever been
made like that's [ __ ] that still will
never make sense to me yeah
didn't um ninja move to florida
probably
i
yeah i think so yeah because jessica
post that posted that she was in florida
too
everybody loves florida everyone's
moving down everybody's moving to
florida yeah nick merc's already lived
here i think tim the tatman lives like
moved here
like wouldn't surprise me if ninja did
too
but you know turner reps floated pretty
hard so i feel like tyler's probably
been kind of quiet about it yeah yeah
he also you know he got abused like you
don't want to
oh man he went through some [ __ ] too
ninja like
he was top dog and turner like
completely dethroned him like to where
it wasn't even
have you guys seen the ksi tifu vs ninja
video no oh my god it's one of the
funniest things i've ever seen yeah you
should throw that on real quick
hey ksi ninja versus you guys know ksi
yeah i know he's one of the biggest
youtubers on the planet
yeah he did a uh a little commentary
it needs volume
[Music]
oh i think i have seen this a long time
ago
and how many views does this have
seven million yeah then turner reacted
to it and they got another like yeah 14
million on turner's channel oh my god on
the reaction this is literally a video
of like ksi kind of just [ __ ] on
ninja but like without having to because
turner like
oh no you got to watch at least the
first video do this
dude
you don't hear much about fortnite these
days it's because nobody plays it no no
what does everybody play now i have no
idea i don't play anything no no
you think there's gonna be like a next
big fortnight
yeah 100 percent that's got to be
something yeah it's going to be
something it's going to be something
that's vr based i bet though vr yeah
it's going to be a huge like a vr game
that like everyone's addicted to
i remember this clip right here
oh yeah he's he's [ __ ] spamming him
with the rocket launcher this is the
first time they ever matched up
[Music]
oh yeah he gets that he gets up
all he can do is shoot ninja and kill
him yeah that's tifu he killed me
no what's really funny is like
there's actually a clip in here where
turner
skip forward a couple minutes that's
when turner's dressed as a chicken
yeah right here yeah somewhere in there
yeah check this out this [ __ ] is
hilarious
is that a hacker
he doesn't even he doesn't even react
oh yeah he took out his whole squad yeah
he killed it watch this
so yeah turner took out two of ninja's
boys already
ninja calls him a hacker but this is so
funny oh yeah he says he's hacking
aimbot yeah but they're both live
streaming too so like oh that's
hilarious he's like i'm reporting you
bro
oh does he really say that
oh [ __ ]
so are all their people that are like
in their live chat or they're like
jumping back and forth saying oh my god
it's tifu it's tifu yeah so ninja was
just like focused on the fight so he
wasn't paying attention and people
people mess with ninja all the time yeah
because turner had already killed him a
couple times
[Laughter]
was like all right bro be sure to go to
the theater reports your ass literally
didn't miss a shot the entire time
i found a hacker they just used the chat
everyone's like that's
so sick
it's so funny too how he like somehow
somehow does those crazy like trick
maneuvers yeah he tried to trick shot
him he knew he was going to die we
figured if he could get like the you
know the kill on that it would be like a
good clip but he plays for entertainment
you know he wasn't playing to like
that
but he doesn't he like doesn't even
react when most kids would be like oh my
god
he just like is just like stone-faced
after he does it yeah and then ninja
realizes that he just called him a
hacker when really
i don't know turner's so much better
than ninja that
like to ninja he's cheating yeah because
it doesn't seem possible do they even
play the same game anymore like what is
the game they play now so they first
they've known each other for years but
right fortnight they used to play pub g
against each other
yeah and um i don't really know what
ninja's doing now i know he still live
streams he's probably just playing games
just for fun because tim the tatman and
him are really good friends like he
helped him blow up so i'm sure they're
live streaming together still i still
see him live every now and then but
with i don't know
i really enjoyed watching fortnite i
think it was one of the most enjoyable
games to watch as a viewer that was like
ever created i think some of the end
games in fortnite were some of the most
exciting things to watch like the
tournaments that they would have oh yeah
seeing high pro level players stacked on
top of each other like going to the end
zones like strategies for that was so
nuts and it was so cool to watch like
all the comms between between teams and
everything
and uh now it's just too saturated they
added too much [ __ ] yeah i think if
there was like a fortnight 3.0 that was
like
it would have to be something like
revolutionary to gaming you know like
maybe a vr version of fortnite or
something like that because i just think
the building aspect was really cool
that was almost unique the pros can't
like mastered the mechanics and then
like me as an average player that's just
trying to relax and have fun like i'm
watching somebody who's insane at
building like i'm probably gonna get
smoked you know
yeah but i don't know the gaming world's
crazy i'm definitely
waiting for the next big thing i i'm
very interested to see
when a massive game is going to be
released and tied to like a
cryptocurrency because i think that
that's in the future for gamers there
are a ton of those play to earn games
yeah there's a ton yeah but like
one that like microsoft or like ubisoft
or someone like that releases like a map
you know
fortnite attached to like like that's a
play to earn game the new gta yeah yeah
something like that you know because uh
i don't know i think
everything's going digital
i